Music.
Herzlich willkommen bei,
Dicke Bretter, ähm ein Podcast, der in Wechsel mit dem Chaosradio läuft. Ich bin Elina Eickstedt und,
Ich bin heute hier zusammen mit äh Konstanze kurz und mit,
Anna, wie ist er die? Genau, Elisa ist heute nicht da, ähm deswegen haben wir uns Anna eingeladen und,
Es soll heute um ein Thema gehen, was ich nicht so direkt mit,
Gesetzgebung beschäftigt, so wie wir das im letzten Podcast hatten, sondern,
Ähm um ein Thema für das ich glaube Anna und Konstanze die größten Experten sind wo gibt's? Auf jeden Fall haben sie sehr viel Zeit mit diesem Thema verbracht, nämlich das Thema,
Untersuchungsausschüsse und da ist natürlich die Frage, wann kommt
denn so ein Untersuchungsausschuss zustande was macht der dann und ähm warum braucht man den und vielleicht auch, was ist denn eigentlich dann das Ergebnis und der Einfluss auf das
gesamte Weltgeschehen von so einem Untersuchungsausschuss.
Genau, also wir hätten in der Vergangenheit mehrfach mit Untersuchungsausschüssen zu tun, aber ähm doch die ganze Bundesrepublik hat mit diesen Ausschüssen zu tun, da viele zumindest die im Bundestag eine recht hohe Öffentlichkeit.
Wirksamkeit haben, würde ich sagen. Also es gibt immer wieder Themen, die werden besprochen und dann auch von der Presse begleitet,
Und Anna hier, die hat mal die Ehre gehabt, mehrere Jahre einen ziemlich wichtigen Untersuchungsausschuss zu begleiten und auch zu protokollieren
nehme ich den NSA, BND Untersuchungsausschuss und da werden wir heute bestimmt einige Beispiele hören und auch ein paar hoffentlich geile Anekdoten,
Denn in der Zeit ist natürlich auch einfach einiges passiert oder kamen einige Aussagen in diesem Untersuchungsausschuss zustande, die einfach.
Noch mal reflektiert gehören, aber wir wollen vielleicht auch ein bisschen nachher auf die europäische Ebene wechseln,
denn Untersuchungsausschüsse sind ja nicht eine Eigenart des Bundestages, sondern
werden natürlich anderswo auch gehandhabt und wir werden mal gucken, ob wir wenigstens ein paar Aspekte bei europäischen Untersuchungsausschüssen ansprechen wollen, würde ich mal sagen.
Aber vielleicht fangen wir erst mal ganz von Anfang an, auch im Kleinen, also mit der deutschen Ebene und ähm
Konstanza hat jetzt schon gesagt, es gab ein NSA, BND Untersuchungsausschuss und das sind parlamentarische Untersuchungsausschüsse. Wann,
kommt es eigentlich dann dazu, dass es so ein Untersuchungsausschuss gibt oder der einberufen wird.
Also endlich ist es ein interessantes Mittel der Opposition, wenn ähm Untersuchungsausschüsse werden in der Regel initiiert
entweder von einer ganz großen Mehrheit der Parlamentarier, also dass sich alle Fraktionen oder fast alle Fraktionen zu so einem Untersuchungsausschuss zusammentun,
Oder aber, dass eben die Opposition genug Stimmen zusammenbekommt, um jemand also einen Untersuchungsausschuss einzusetzen. Das muss nämlich nur ein Viertel der Parlamentarier sein.
Können also quasi gegen die Regierung durchgesetzt werden. Insofern ist es im klassischen Instrument der Opposition.
Genau, jetzt hatten wir aber ja bei dem BND NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss die Situation, dass wir hatten ja eine nicht nur eine große Koalition, sondern wir hatten ja eine
große Koalition und die Opposition hatte ja nur 20 Prozent und dann hatten sie sich eben darauf geeinigt
also haben zusammen was ausgearbeitet und sich dann gemeinsam darauf geeinigt, haben sich dann aber auch darauf geeinigt, dass die Opposition sogenannte Minderheitenrechte bekommt, damit sie überhaupt was machen können,
weil ja auch die Zusammensetzung im Ausschuss damit zusammenhängt, also wie viele Leute von welcher Partei da drin sitzen,
die Prozentzahlen sind und damit sie überhaupt quasi was machen können, haben sie dann als Opposition schon ein Viertel der Sitze bekommen, weil sonst hätten sie das auch nicht geschafft. Das heißt, wenn man eine ganz große Koalition hat und das
doof läuft, dann kann man als Opposition auch nicht mehr viel machen,
Genau. Ähm wir wissen vielleicht mal sagen, wo die rechtlichen Grundlagen liegen, die liegen sogar im Grundgesetz.
Äh der Artikel 44 hat sozusagen paar wenige Regeln für so Untersuchungsausschüsse im Bundestag, aber es gibt ein eigenes Gesetz, das PU AG was wir damals glaube ich auch mal,
Tiertappen, als es losging mit dem Protokollieren vom NSA, BND Untersuchungsausschuss. Ähm
wo aber nicht alles irgendwie festgenagelt ist, sondern auch um
paar Möglichkeiten bestehen, dass ich Mehrheiten der Parlamentarier zusammentun und bestimmte Rechte einsetzen oder nicht einsetzen, insbesondere die Öffentlichkeit äh dieses Ausschusses und und solche Fragen, also
organisatorische Fragen würde ich Sie jetzt mal nennen. Genau, vielleicht gehen wir noch mal zurück zu dem, was können die eigentlich überhaupt machen, also so was, ne, weil der Untersuchungsausschuss war ja was
untersuchen. Das heißt, klassischerweise kriegen wir den immer, wenn es irgendein großes Thema gibt, das jetzt irgendwie super im öffentlichen Interesse ist, wie zum Beispiel eben diese ganze NSA BND-Skandal oder,
Wirecard oder weiß ich nicht, was gab's noch, NSU? Gab's ja ganz viele nicht nur im Bund, sondern auch da gibt's halt nämlich auch,
Auch nicht. Oder oder genau. Ach ja stimmt, das wollen wir nicht unbedingt die Ausnahmen besprechen, aber die meisten Landtage haben dieses Recht auch. Ja.
Genau und die dürfen ja sowas ähnliches wie in so einem Gerichtsprozess. Das heißt, sie dürfen.
Zeuginnen laden, die dürfen Sachverständige laden und die dürfen auch andere dazu auffordern, Ermittlungen zu machen, zum Beispiel andere Behörden und dann können die denen sagen, hier, liefern wir mal alle
Fakten zu dem Thema, die ihr so habt und dann müssen die die ran schaffen. Das heißt, die haben schon relativ viel Rechte, zumindest aufm Papier
Okay, jetzt hat Konstanze eben gesagt, das ist so ein bisschen auch ein Mittel, was die Opposition für sich nutzen kann. Macht man also ist das,
Kann man sich das vorstellen, dass es einfach ein auch ein Mittel der Informationsgewinnung ist oder was ist sozusagen der politische Hebel,
für den man so einen Untersuchungsausschuss nutzen kann als Opposition.
Na ja, um die Exekutive zu kontrollieren, ne. Also ich meine, das ist ja so alles, was irgendwie du kontrollierst, was deine Exekutive, also deine Regierung und deine Behörden so irgendwie machen und dann musste der Kram rangeschafft werden. Also ich meine, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie zum.
NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss gehen, dann du kannst ja normalerweise nicht hingehen und sagen, hier lieber BND, gib mir mal all die Akten, so dann lachen die und äh
So ist so, aber haben wir auch so hoch, ne? Aber ansonsten ist ja noch schwieriger. Wenn du gerade so eine Institution.
Kontrollieren willst und dich überhaupt mal informieren willst, wenn du jetzt nicht im parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium oder sonst wo sitzt dann brauchst du einen Untersuchungsausschuss
Ich würde aber auch sagen, also ich hätte mir jetzt mal so die Liste angesehen, der Untersuchungsausschüsse diesen ist natürlich in der Wikipedia verzeichnet. Sie sind schon auch politisiert, also.
Äh manchmal ist auch eine Drohung mit einem Untersuchungsausschuss durchaus ein politisches Mittel, muss da nicht unbedingt erfolgen, aber man sieht so ein bisschen, dass einiges an diesen Untersuchungsausschüssen vielleicht nicht unbedingt die bundespolitisch wichtigsten Themen sind.
Aber dennoch eingesetzt werden. Ich glaube
Ähm manchmal insbesondere bei so einem Sonderfall, denn der Verteidigungsausschuss, der kann sich auch zu einem Untersuchungsausschuss wandeln. Ähm
Ja, da sieht man oft politisiert ist, denn da ist ja keiner Öffentlichkeit gegeben oder kaum einer. Der Verteidigungsausschuss entdeck
Tag der geheim. Dann sieht man halt trotzdem, dass es benutzt wird. Also etwa zum Beispiel in der letzten Legislaturperiode, da gab's den um die Berateraffäre von Ursula von der Leyen. Äh da gab's zwar diesen Untersuchungsausschuss, aber
Eigentlich den Gig wartet nicht zur Information der Öffentlichkeit, sondern eher ein politisches Mittel. Ja.
Mit ähnliches kann man wahrscheinlich auch sagen für die für den Streit den es aktuell gibt um einen eventuellen Untersuchungsausschuss in der ganzen Affäre um diese Privatbank in Hamburg die zählt natürlich auf den aktuellen Bundeskanzler.
Äh also ich denke das schon auch klassische politische Streitmittel äh dennoch.
Denke die letzten Untersuchungsausschüsse sowohl im Bund wie auch im Land haben trotzdem in ihrer Gesamtheit meistens auch wirklich wichtige gesellschaftspolitische Themen betroffen
Ja und vor allem ist es ja auch ein Mittel, um ein Thema lange im Bewusstsein zu halten, weil du ja immer wieder,
passiert irgendwas und selbst wenn der jetzt nicht öffentlich stattfindet, ich meine irgendwo sickert immer irgendwas an irgendwem und damit kochst du ja so ein Thema über,
Im Zweifelsfall Jahre auf. Also ich meine, nicht alle Untersuchungsausschüsse dauern eine Legislaturperiode, ne? Das muss man irgendwie auch sehen, wenn die kurz vor der Legislatur,
kurz vor Legislaturende eingesetzt werden, dann sind die dann auch vorbei erstmal. So und dann müsste man einen neuen einsetzen, aber man hat ja trotzdem schon, ich sage mal, eine.
Eine größere politische Dauer als so die normale, politische Aufmerksamkeitsspanne
Jetzt müssen wir vielleicht ein paar sagen. Also man braucht eine Art Beschluss,
äh den der Bundestag fällt über den Inhalt des Untersuchungsausschusses. Daran müssen sich dann diejenigen, die in dem Untersuchungsausschuss sitzen, auch halten.
Ja, der Untersuchungsauftrag ist das ja genau. Das heißt, Sie dürfen dann die einigen sich darauf, was Sie untersuchen,
Wollen wir oft drauf referenzieren und das heißt, wenn ich diesen Untersuchungsauftrag sozusagen durchbekommen habe, dann setzt sich das aber anhand der ohnehin schon,
bestehenden Mehrheiten zusammen oder kann es dann solche Sonderfälle geben, wie du jetzt eben gesagt hast ähm,
Wie wird der dann besetzt der Untersuchungsausfluss? Ist das auch demokratisch geregelt oder ist das so ein bisschen Verhandlungssache? Eine Wiederbesetzt wird es ja in der Regel nach der Stärke der,
Nach den Mehrheiten sozusagen auch gesetzlich geregelt in diesem PU AG.
Und könnte man sich ja vorstellen, dass der Bundestag sehr viele Fraktionen hat, jeder einzelne Fraktion muss auch vertreten sein. Das heißt natürlich, dass es eine bestimmte Größe erreichen muss, denn man hat immer ein normales Mitglied
Und von jeder Fraktion auch einen stellvertretenden Mitglied. Da kann man sich ja die ausrechnen. Denke, es sind jetzt immer neun und waren auch im hm NSA, BND Untersuch,
Tavonus acht. Ah, okay. Genau. Acht und dann noch mal acht Stellvertretende. Okay. Und natürlich einen Vorsitzenden und davon auch für Jens Stellvertretenden.
Kommt der sozusagen dazu oder es wird der nur bestimmt mit drin, glaube ich. Immer eigentlich die Fraktionen sind frei.
Ihre Mitglieder dann zu bestimmen. Also ist dann Sache der Fraktion nicht. Der Bundestag bestimmt die, sondern die einzelnen Fraktionen. Also faktisch ist, auch wenn wir abgerufen wird. Den Fall gab's ja auch häufiger. Glaube sogar beim NSA, BND- und Untersuchungsausschuss, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Und okay und warum sind die also vielleicht zur Historie? Das haben wir jetzt noch nicht gesagt, ne, der NSA, BND Untersuchungsausschuss war von 20014 bis 20 siebzehn. Ähm,
Da hatte ich noch nicht so viel mit Netzpolitik am Hut. Deswegen äh also der angesprochene
NSL, BND-Untersuchungsausschuss ist natürlich eine ganz klare Folge der Snowden. Ja. Äh Veröffentlichung, die ja zweitausenddreizehn im Juni begann, also
da ist ganz ganz deutlich eine Reaktion zu sehen. Soweit ich weiß, ist der deutsche Bundestag der einzige Parlament der Welt, der so eine Art Untersuchungsausschuss eingesetzt hat zu dem Thema,
Obwohl sehr viele betroffen waren und auch sehr viele andere Staaten ähnliche Rechte haben, also so eine Art
Enquete oder Untersuchungsausschuss machen können. Da war Deutschland echt, muss ich sagen,
An der Stelle vielleicht noch mal der Unterschied, was ist der Unterschied zwischen einer Enquete-Kommission und einem Untersuchungsausschuss? Ich weiß, du warst auch schon in Enquete-Kommissionen so hohen großen Unterschied ähm ein bisschen in der Art der Richter
Untersuchungsausschuss hat so ein bisschen angelehnt, die Rechte wie die Strafprozessordnung, also ähnlich wie bei einem Gerichtsverfahren und die.
Eigentlich ähm untersuchend im Wort sind. Die soll sich also einem Thema nähern ohne einen Skandal oder so zu beleuchten oder Zeugen zu befragen, sondern eher ein Thema,
Aber tatsächlich ähm so vom eigentlichen Auftrag ist es schon ähnlich. Äh die Enquete sind nicht so stark politisiert, würde ich sagen,
Und die sind auch ein bisschen anders von der Zusammensetzung. Wir sind größer ähm wer selbst mal Mitglied einer Enquete-Kommission im deutschen Bundestag, denn die ist in der Regel auch besetzt mit Menschen,
nämlich zur Hälfte, die nicht zum Parlament gehören, sondern die als Sachverständige berufen werden, jeweils auf Antrag der Fraktion,
Aber auch da ist diese Zusammensetzung nach Proport und äh ja
Da gibt's ähnliche Regelungen. Also solche Ausschüsse haben eine bestimmte Geschäftsordnung und die ähm die Regelung des Ältestenrates Bundestags, die gelten und und solche formalen Dinge. Also die die würden für eine Enquete-Kommission auch gelten.
Hm okay, haben wir jetzt sozusagen die formalen Kriterien na, noch nicht ganz. Vielleicht sollten wir noch sagen, ähm,
Welche Aufgabe eigentlich der Vorsitzende oder die Vorsitzende hat im Wesentlichen ist das so eine Art ja
Ja, Führung der, ja, der Zeugenbefragung so ein bisschen Einhaltung der Regeln.
Kann man so sagen, oder? Ja,
Okay und dann sollten wir noch das Ergebnis kurz besprechen. Also ganz am Ende sozusagen, wenn man die ganzen Zeugen gehört hat, dann gibt's eine Art Ergebnisbericht
Aber beim NSA, BND Untersuchungsausschuss, äh da gab's das, was es häufig gibt, nämlich sogenannte Sondervoten,
Wenn sich nämlich ähm ja die Parlamentarier nicht einigen konnten aufm Abschlussbericht, dann dürfen sie quasi eine Art Minderheitenmeinung
Abgeben. Ah, okay. Und die war auch sehr lang. Weißt du noch, wie lang der Bericht insgesamt war? Boah, nee, das weiß ich nicht. Aber der war richtig lang. Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie als tausend Seiten, oder? Ich fand's, es war irgendwie so eine
so ein so ein fast einen Meter Ordner, wenn man das und ich habe den einmal ausgedruckt gesehen. Das ist auf jeden Fall schon schon dolle und ja, da ging's ja ganz viel um die Frage.
War's jetzt Massenüberwachung oder war es China?
So und da konnten sie sich ja überhaupt nicht einigen. Und am Ende, wie bei den meisten ähm ja so Enquetes oder Untersuchungsausschüssen, auch anderswo auf der Welt,
Würde natürlich ins Plenum gebracht. Also der Bundestag hat dann noch mal eine Plenardebatte. Die wurde hier auch relativ stark mit sehr starken Statement
geführt. Also ich weiß noch, dass ich mir die live angesehen habe und also da haben sich die Oppositionspolitiker und die damaligen regierende Politiker schon ganz schön drüber hakt.
Also damals hat sich etwa die CDU auf den Standpunkt gestellt. Man könnte hier nicht von technisierter Massenüberwachung reden, also da schon sehr divergierende,
Äh ja so Stellungnahmen. Ja weißt du warum das keine Massenüberwachung war? Nee.
Weil wenn du nämlich 1hundert Kekse hast und du isst einen, dann sind das nicht massenhaft Kekse.
Ah. Nämlich Marion Wendt, glaube ich, im Untersuchungsausschuss. Was? Versucht noch irgendwie zu rechtfertigen, weil es gibt ja ganz viele Kommunikationsdaten und überhaupt ganz viele Daten aufer Welt, ne? Und wenn ich dann aus meinen hundert,
Datenkeksen einen Keks esse, dann habe ich nicht massenhaft Kekse gegessen und deshalb ist das keine Massenüberwachung. Erschließe ich mir auch unmittelbar.
Stimmt die ich weiß gar nicht wann wann kam die diese äh die äh Entscheidung vom vom ähm europäischen Gerichtshof dazu mit dem human in the Loop, wenn dann irgendwo ein Mensch draufguckt. Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Ich krieg's grad nicht zusammen.
Okay, massenhaft Kekse
Ja. Spannend. Aber vielleicht äh gehen wir noch mal ganz zum Anfang zurück, ne? Es ist 2014 und äh der NSA, BND Untersuchungsausschuss startet und irgendwie würde man ja denken, dass bei so einem,
sehr wichtigen Thema doch
Also die mediale Aufmerksamkeit war wahrscheinlich relativ hoch. Ähm man würde jetzt denken, na ja, so Ausschusssitzungen werden ja häufig auch gestreamt. Das ist da ja,
nicht so richtig der Fall gewesen. Wie ist das denn? Werden solche Ausschüsse übertragen oder welches, was sind die Bedingungen
Warum sie nicht übertragen werden? Ich weiß, dass du und Andre, also du, Anna und Andre Meister äh beide zusammen da sehr viel Zeit verbracht habe in diesem Ausschuss. Ähm
Wie ist es denn dazu gekommen? Genau, das Ding ist, dass diese Zeugenanhörungen, die sind erst mal,
nicht streambar, ne. Es sind ja auch so Zeugen und da dürfen tatsächlich auch dann während der Sitzung darf dann keiner irgendwie ein Foto machen oder so. Also wie im Gericht
quasi was gestreamt wurde, waren die paar Sachverständigenanhörungen. Das heißt jetzt irgendwie nicht Leute, die da,
saßen, weil sie zum Beispiel beim BND gearbeitet haben und irgendwas über ihre Arbeit aussagen sollten, sondern.
Zu Juristen, die irgendwie ganz viel Geheimdienstexpertinnen waren oder irgendwie ein Drohnenpilot aus den USA. Das sind dann Sachen, wo die Leute quasi als als Zeugen da waren,
die nicht als wo die Leute nicht als Zeugen da waren, sondern als Sachverständige und die wurden teilweise gestreamt. Der Rest war eben,
zwar öffentlich, das heißt irgendwie jede Person kann da einfach hingehen und sich auf die Besuchertribüne setzen, aber das wurde eben nicht aufgenommen, sondern von den Stenographinnen und Stenographen des Bundestages mitprotokolliert
aber die Protokolle, das war schon von Anfang an klar, werden dann auch erst veröffentlicht, wenn der Ausschuss
vorbei ist und dann ist es natürlich zumindest für die öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit ein bisschen arg spät. Das Argument dafür,
Zeugen sollen ja nicht beeinflusst werden. Das heißt, es ist ja so ein bisschen wie bei Gericht auch, ne, wenn,
Der eine sagt, weiß ich nicht, äh einmal zum Mordzeitpunkt war der irgendwie bei mir zu Hause aufm Sofa und wenn dann der andere sagt,
ja zu dem Zeitpunkt war ich aber ganz woanders, dann will man ja nicht, dass der eine hört, was der andere gesagt hat und dass sie sich dann irgendwie beeinflussen können und deshalb wurde das alles.
Nicht zu dem Zeitpunkt veröffentlichten. Wir haben aber gesagt, das geht gar nicht, weil dann kann man damit nix anfangen, weil so eine normale Redaktion,
leistet sich's ja nicht irgendwie jemanden, da stundenlang irgendwie reinzusetzen. Also die längste Sitzung ging fast 13 Stunden und da ist so ein normaler Arbeitstag hier vorbei und dann ist dann eben auch keiner mehr da und
Bei den größeren Redaktionen, was so jetzt weiß ich nicht, Zeit und irgendwie.
Die Welt saß da oft mit rum, aber die kamen dann halt irgendwie vor allem zu den Sitzungen, wo so prominente Zeugen saßen. Das heißt, ne, wenn Angela Merkel kommt, ne, dann ist auch die Presse ganz viel da. Das ist klar. Aber wenn da jetzt so ein kleiner BND Sachbearbeiter kommt,
sind die eben oft auch nicht da oder nur am Anfang irgendwie der Sachen und gerade dann passieren ja oft die spannenden Sachen,
weil das ja die Leute sind, die wirklich mit dem Zeug arbeiten, die also wirklich im BND sitzen und das machen und die dann eben spannende Sachen erzählen können. Und dementsprechend haben wir uns halt dazu entschieden.
Jo, wir ziehen uns den ganzen Kram rein,
zumindest die öffentlichen Sitzungen und protokollieren das mit, damit man was hat, wo man drauf zurückgreifen kann, auch bevor die Aufmerksamkeit dann vorbei ist.
Wollen wir mal noch mal kurz ähm Revue passieren lassen, wer waren denn diese Promis, wo alle saßen? Also ist ja eine ganze Reihe. Du hast eben Merkel erwähnt, weißt du, jetzt aus meinem Kopf noch mehr?
Na, Merkel war da, Steinmeier war da. Bundespräsident, der war als Ex- äh Kanzleramtschef da, ne? Genau, dann war die,
ganzen BND-Präsidenten waren da. Mein Schindle war da, wie hieß der andere Maaßen? War auch der Maaßen war auch da, genau.
Ich glaube, das war es waren das also primär sozusagen waren die als Betroffene sozusagen geladen oder wie kann man sich das vorstellen? Oder als,
Na schon so als Verantwortung klar bei Merkel kannst du sie denken,
dann wirst du gefragt, hier Frau Merkel, ne, die Amis sollen ihr Handy abgehört haben, was äh haben sie denn davon gehalten und dann wurde ja auch irgendwie relativ lange gesagt, uh, es soll so ein no spye ab
geben. Danach hat sich rausgestellt, eigentlich stand das nie so richtig zur Debatte, weil eigentlich hätte, also eigentlich
gab's Kommunikation, wo relativ klar waren, die USA haben da gar keinen Bock drauf und dazu wurde halt auch gefragt und bei Steinmeier ging's ja ganz, ganz viel um diese
Drohnensachen glaube ich auch und und mit Abkommen, was damals schon bestand. Ja. Bei Steinmeier hat mich am meisten irritiert, was der für eine unglaubliche amüsierte. Der wusste ja gar nix aus seiner Zeit, als wenn er nicht dabei gewesen ist. Der hatte wirklich
unglaubliche Gedächtnisbild und da hat immer weiß nicht, kann ich nicht. Aber,
Haben wir bisher noch nicht erwähnt, hm, es gab zwei Teile dieses Ausschusses. Anna hat jetzt immer darüber geredet, was der öffentliche Teil und der wurde natürlich auch protokollierter
Ähm aber es gab ja auch noch einen zweiten Teil, nämlich den nichtöffentlichen Bereich und das ist eine Besonderheit, denn eigentlich.
Tagen die Untersuchungsausschüsse öffentlich, aber man kann natürlich davon eine Ausnahme beschließen und das ist natürlich bei den Geheimdienstleuten besonders verbreitet. Ich würde sagen fifty fifty.
134 Sitzungen, 66 öffentlich, also ja tatsächlich ziemlich ziemlich Punktlandung. Und die werden dann auch
nicht protokolliert oder werden die Protokolle sind nicht öffentlich oder die werden protokolliert. Die Protokolle sind nicht öffentlich und die haben, das muss man aber auch dazu sagen, in der Regel nicht so lange gedauert
weil also kannst du dir so vorstellen, du sitzt erst mal in so einer öffentlichen Sitzung und dann.
Gut, weiß ich nicht, wird der BNDler gefragt. A stand auf ihrer Liste da, der Hans Zimmermann aus Hintertupfingen so und dann sagte er
Nur das kann ich nicht öffentlich sagen und dann geht das ein paar Mal so weiter und dann schreiben die sich auf, was der nicht öffentlich sagen kann und was er eigentlich trotzdem wissen wollen und dann sagt man, okay jetzt jetzt machen wir hier eine nicht öffentliche Sitzung und dann fragen wir all das, was er vorher nicht gesagt hat.
Und ist das, ist das ein Sonderfall jetzt, weil
der BND da so extrem involviert war oder ist das eigentlich die Regel bei so Untersuchungsausschuss Geschichten? Nee, ist da schon deutlich mehr als Sachen. Also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel
den Wirecard-Untersuchungsausschuss nehmen oder den Edati Untersuchungsausschuss oder so, dann äh selbst beim NSU-Untersuchungsausschuss, wo ja auch
Geheimdienste involviert waren, selbst da war der Anteil nie so groß. Und es gibt noch so eine besondere Anomalie. Anderer kann die bestimmt ganz toll beschreiben. Da saß nämlich immer noch
so ein Typ oder eine, manchmal zwei, ne, vom Bundeskanzleramt, die sich ab und an zwischendurch gemeldet. Die Aufpasser, ja. Und immer wieder betont haben, dass bestimmte Zeugen hier nicht weitersprechen dürfen. Die hatten doch so eine bestimmte Phrase.
Das ist nicht von Ihrer Ausnahmegenehmigung gedeckt oder dass es nicht Teil des Untersuchungsauftrags. Genau. Genau, das wäre natürlich so eine Besonderheit. Das heißt auch ähm,
zum Beispiel jemand wie Angela Merkel oder Frank-Walter Steinmeier äh wurden da quasi von den Hanseln hinten darauf hingewiesen, dass sie hier nicht weiter sprechen dürfen. Also da jetzt nicht nur irgendwelche Beamten auf dem auf der mittleren Ebene, sondern auch durchaus die
Ex-Chefs. Also Steinmeier war ja etwa äh Bundeskanzleramtchef und damit ist er ja auch der oberste Aufsicher äh Aufseher über den Bundesnachrichtendienst. Also die wurden auch ziemlich regelmäßig oder
Ja, ich glaube, es kam so ein bisschen auf die Zeugen an, ne. Also ich meine,
Klar, von welcher Behörde die kommen und wer jetzt Ihr Aufpasser ist, das ist ja dann unterschiedlich, je nachdem, wo du gerade irgendwie bist und ich meine, es würde sagen, es gibt so mehrere Typen von Zeugen, ne? Es gibt so die Zeugen, die haben eh keinen Bock und die erinnern sich halt an nix.
Herr Steinmeier. Dann muss man halt ja es gab ja auch noch mehr, ne, die sich an nicht viel erinnert haben. Und da muss man nicht viel machen. Dann gab's irgendwie, ich meine, die meisten BND-Zeugen hatten ja irgendwie als Anwalt auch noch dabei irgendwie den Johnny Eisenberg, der war ja auch,
Ich sage mal,
aktiv so. Der hat ja auch dafür gesorgt, dass die nicht irgendwie zu viel sagen und dann hat er irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, sich darum gekümmert, dass jetzt der Zeuge aber dolle erschöpft ist und dass man jetzt auch nicht mehr weitermachen kann und so und das sind jetzt überall ein Taxi rufen soll
Okay, also war das sozusagen wirklich wie ein Anwalt oder war das ein Anwalt bekommen und das ist auch
Also dadurch, dass das Gerichtsverfahren ähnlich ist, ist es auch das auch üblich jemanden mit an die Seite zu geben sollten wir doch durch den Ablauf auch mal erklären, dass man sich eine Idee,
mit dem Abfall fällst du dir so der Fotzen eröffnet und je nach Proport
können Fragen gestellt werden an die jeweils Geladenen. Ähm ich glaube, da gibt's noch eine festgelegte Reihenfolge, wenn ich mich äh richtig erinnere, ne? Ja, ich glaube, da gab's irgendwie nur fest.
In den normalen Ausschuss ist es ja so, dass es nach Größe der Fraktion geht. Genau und da gibt's immer so Runden. Ja, machen Sie eine Fragerunde und dann,
Und häufig ähm haben dann die Fragesteller auch angeknüpft.
An das, was zum Beispiel, wenn sie für eine halbe Stunde vorher dran waren, sie gefragt haben. Also es war immer ein bisschen zeitversetzt nicht wirklich ein gerichtliches Gespräch war, wie man's hätte im Gerichtssaal, sondern irgendwie so ein bisschen entzerrt. Ja, voll.
Genau. Und die durften auch vorher ein Eingangsstatement machen. Das durften sie halt auch alle, ne? Nee, nicht alle. Die Geladenen, die genau.
Manche haben gar kein Eingangsstatement gemacht und sind dann gleich befragt worden
Ja, die haben gesagt, sie wollen nix sagen, außer das, weiß ich nicht. Also manche haben auch einfach nur gesagt, hier der BND hält sich in Richtung Gesetz. Ich bin ein guter deutscher Beamter jetzt los. Ähm und da vielleicht die Frage bei den Eingangsstatements, also ich kenne das halt aus dem normalen Ausschuss,
Sitzung, wo man dann geladen wird als Expertin jetzt, sodass man vorher auch Fragen bekommt. Ist das auch so? Oder ist das dann unabhängig davon, dass sie halt einfach nur einen Eingangszentrum bringen.
Nee, ich glaube, die haben keine Fragen oder so wo jetzt gesagt wurde, ne, dazu wollen wir was von ihnen.
Ich meine, denen war ja schon klar, warum sie geladen werden, weil die haben ja entsprechend irgendwie gearbeitet, aber die haben jetzt nicht so eine Fragenliste bekommen, wo sie dann irgendwie was zu sagen konnten, sondern die hatten die Gelegenheit, aber eben auch nicht die Verpflichtungen,
Am Anfang was zu sagen.
Also ich hab's solche Situationen auch tatsächlich im Gericht schon erlebt, äh wie wir sie jetzt beschrieben hatten, also dass jemand, der auch einen Behördenchef
Wie zum Beispiel ein Geheimdienstchef während seiner Aussage im Gericht auf seine ähm sozusagen ja quasi Geheimhaltungspflichten
hingewiesen wird. Also ich habe so was etwa bei einer Anhörung in Karlsruhe beim Bundesverfassungsgericht auch schon erlebt. Steht halt hinten jemand auf und sagt, hier hat der Herr Präsident
keine Aussagegenehmigung. Es ist also nicht unbedingt auf den Bundestag ähm dass man ja, dass man sehr genau, gerade bei sensiblen Dingen darauf achtet.
Bestimmte Sache, die ausgesprochen werden und wenn man's jetzt so ein bisschen äh betrachtet von einer rechtlichen Perspektive, dann gibt's so diesen sogenannten Kernbereich der exekutiven Eigengestaltung oder Eigenverantwortung.
Es gibt so einen ganz so einen so einen engen Bereich des Regierungshandelns, wo die Bundesregierung einfach nicht auskunftspflichtig ist, wenn das nicht ein abgeschlossener Vorgang
Und da wurde, denke ich, auch oft drauf referenziert. Ich weiß nicht, ob das auch so genannt wird. Nee, den Begriff, dann den erinnere ich mich in dem Kontext nicht. Es war einfach ganz viel
Es ist nicht von der Aussagegenehmigung gedeckt oder es ist halt nicht Teil des Untersuchungsaufwand. Die haben ja auch den Untersuchungsauftrag dann später noch mal erweitert
weil sie gemerkt haben, ne, da kommen noch Sachen dazu, von denen wussten wir am Anfang gar nichts. Das heißt, wir konnten die auch gar nicht in den Untersuchungsauftrag aufnehmen, weil wir gar nicht wussten, dass so was existiert hätte,
Und dann haben sie den noch mal offiziell erweitert, damit eben nicht einfach.
Jeder von den Zeugen sagen kann, so hier, das ist nicht Teil des Untersuchungsauftrags, dazu sage ich nix. Und wie ist es, wenn Sie diesen Untersuchungsauftrag erweitern, ist muss das dann sozusagen noch mal durch durch den gesamten Prozess laufen oder
ist das einfacher möglich
Oh, das weiß ich gar nicht. Nee, das ist auch gesetzlich geregelt, dafür ein bisschen zu bestimmte Mehrheiten haben, aber sie müssen's auch explizit tun. Ähm ich fand's für den NSA, BND Untersuchungsausschuss schon bemerkenswert, wie stark
ähm sich das gewandelt hat wegen der Erst- und die NSA-Skandale, um sozusagen Deutschland als Opfer
Ja. Und es wurde dann sehr viel mehr die Frage, inwieweit ist Deutschland Mittäter durch den Bundesnachrichtendienst äh viel stärker auf dieser ganzen Geheimverträge,
Ähm kennt ihr das? Fast kann man sagen, oh eine Vervielfachung des Untersuchungsgegenständes, würde ich sagen. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ich glaube, das hat am Ende also,
Ausmaße angenommen oder vor allem ne, das kam wie so ein Bumerang zurück, das hätte man wahrscheinlich am Anfang nicht gedacht.
Ich hatte damals mal Gelegenheit unmittelbar nach dem Ende mit dem damals dort sehr aktiven Politiker, der es leider schon verstorben, Hans-Christian Schwöbel zu sprechen. Wir haben von Netzpolitik Org ein Podcast mit ihm gemacht. Ähm
Und der hat so ein bisschen von seiner Seite berichtet, wie er diesen Ausschuss empfunden hat. Das fand ich sehr interessant.
Das war bereits sein fünfter Geheimdienst Untersuchungsausschuss. Das fand ich eine enorme Menge. Der hat also über die verschiedenen Legislaturperioden davon einige mitgemacht. Die gab's immer wieder
Ist ja nix Neues. Das ist die Geheimdienste in Skandale verwickelt sind und er hat sich sehr empört gezeigt. Der hat damals ähm,
auch sein Erstaunen zum Ausdruck gebracht, wie stark er belogen wurde, wie sehr sie ihn da ins Gesicht gelogen haben.
Ähm wie sehr er durch das Aktenstudium, da wurden ja eine Menge Akten beigezogen bemerkt hat, welche Aussagen falsch waren und äh aber auch, wie sehr er sich dadurch,
hindert gefühlt hat, dass das Rederecht so kurz war. Also er hatte viel mehr Fragen, die er hätte stellen wollen und die sich auch nach der Aktenlage ergeben haben, als er dann rankam. Und er hat auch sich beschwert, dass insbesondere die Regierungsfraktion ähm,
Ja, durch extensives Labern, ja, quasi die Zeit blockiert hätten. Also er hätte,
sehr gerne mehr Fragen gestellt. Er war aber auch in einer sehr exponierten Situation, denn er war auch Mitglied im parlamentarischen Kontrollausschuss. Das heißt, er hatte ein exklusives Wissen,
Insofern, also es war interessant. Wir können wir vielleicht also ja genau, wir verlinken das auf jeden Fall in. Vielleicht müssen wir doch mal erklären, was der parlamentarische Kontrollausschuss denn eigentlich
Macht, wenn du das jetzt gerade äh.
So und einen richtigen Zusammenhang gibt's hier nicht, denn eine parlamentarische Kontrollgremium ist ein ständig tagender Ausschuss der der Kontrolle der Geheimdienste gilt. Ähm und da war Hans-Christian Schröbe lange Mitglied. Ja, der ist eben so paritätisch
äh besetzt. Aber wir haben einen Aspekt, glaube ich, noch unerwähnt gelassen, der auch,
echt umstritten war und eigentlich auch eine unglaubliche Politbosse, nämlich dieser Ermittlungsbeauftragte
Äh der Untersuchungsausschuss hat nämlich die Möglichkeit einen Beauftragten für sechs Monate zu bestimmen
Und hätte in diesem Fall auch getan, deren Teil der Untersuchung für den Ausschuss macht. Ähm und der Sonderbeauftragte? Sie haben den Sonderbeauftragte genannt,
weiß auch gar nicht, ob der im Gesetz so heißt, aber nee, nee, das war doch irgendwie der Sonderbeauftragte war doch ein Kompromiss, weil die sollten ja nicht in diese Selektorenlisten rein
Gucken, das heißt, nicht quasi in diese Listen, mit denen der BND dann irgendwie die Sachen gefiltert hat und irgendwie die Verkehre dann irgendwie auszusuchen. Das,
durften sie nicht selber, weil keiner von den Geheimdiensten und der Regierung wollte, dass sie da reingucken und dann war so der.
Schlechte Kompromiss, man setzt irgendeinen Sonderbeauftragten ein, der sozusagen als,
Treuhänder kann man das fast nennen, ne? Der sich das dann irgendwie anguckt und dann am Ende sagt, ob da was Schlimmes drin stand oder nicht. Aber das war dann jemand von den Geheimdiensten, der die entsprechenden Freigaben hat oder wie haben sie den ausgewählt?
Das war Kurt Kraulig, ne? Ja aber Jurist kann man sagen,
Aber der hat sich im Wesentlichen dahingesetzt. Zum BND hat auch schon so ein Kämmerchen gekriegt über
Dass er später auch berichtet hat und hat dann aus BND-Berichten plakiert. Den kannst du nicht anders nennen. Er hat große Teile eines BND Berichts in seinen Bericht rüberkopiert.
Ist natürlich dann auch häufig geworden. Also es war eine unglaubliche Politbosse. Also A, die Einsetzung war sehr umstritten, die Opposition wollte natürlich nicht. Ähm ja, also es war
Ach, ein Teil von den vielen Skandalen.
Also denn eigentlich ging's ja auch mal darum, ob sie Edward Snowden hören können und wie sie ihn eventuell hinkriegen, ja, dass sie ihn nach Deutschland holen oder mit einer Schalte damals, weil das ja auch schon möglich, dass man eine Schalte macht und wurde vor der Pandemie war. Also da gab's schon eine Menge,
Politpossen,
Was war eigentlich deine Lieblingsanekdote aus dem aus dem Untersuchungsausschuss, was ich dir am meisten hängengeblieben? Kannst du auch zwei sagen? Lieblingsanekdote.
Da geht mein Hinweis Weltraumtheorie.
Weltraumtheorie war schon war schon nicht schlecht. Ich musste kurz erklären, was die Weltraum-Theorie ist.
Dann die Weltraumtheorie ist, also ne, man hat ja das Problem, also wenn der BND was in Deutschland macht,
oder machen wollen würde, dann gelten ja relativ strenge Regeln. Ein Auslandsgeheimdienst, der darf ja nicht so viel in Deutschland oder mit Deutschen oder so. Und,
Dann stellt man also dann fragt man sich halt, wenn jetzt der BND einen Satelliten irgendwie abhört.
Und das Zeug, wo man das dann mit empfängt, das steht dann in Deutschland, aber der Satellit, der ist ja da draußen im Bildraum, im Weltraum ist das dann quasi,
in Deutschland mit internationalen Gewässern und ist das so im Ausland und dann kann man natürlich denken, na das ist im Weltraum und dann ist alles okay und das war dann quasi so,
Bad Aibling war das, ne? Das Bad Aibling
und dann hat man quasi gesagt, irgendwie das, was wir in Bad Aiblingen machen, passiert aber eigentlich im Weltraum, weil da ist der Satellit und deshalb gelten diese ganzen Regeln, die man sich irgendwie quasi daran halten müsste, wenn das irgendwie in Deutschland wäre.
Gelden die nicht. Und ich glaube, da hat einer im Ausschuss, da habe ich mich bestens amüsiert. Es kann sogar das es kann sein, dass das Ströble war. Ich weiß es aber nicht mehr genau. Meinte dann noch zu dem,
Herr jetzt aber sagen Sie mal,
Wenn ich einen Sonnenbrand habe, wo entsteht denn der? Im Weltraum oder auf der Erde? So und das war dann wirklich so, ja bisher.
Richtig gut. Also die Weltraumtheorie war schon war schon gut. Das virtuelle Ausland war auch gut. Ach so okay mhm. Virtuelles Auslandsträger. Die Funktionsträger sind auch gut, aber das virtuelle Ausland ist auf jeden Fall
Quasi in Frankfurt, weil wenn man in Frankfurt am Internet knoten Verkehre abhört, die vom Ausland ins Ausland gehen,
Dann ist das ja quasi nicht Deutschland, weil das interessiert einen ja nur das, was vom Ausland ins Ausland geht und deshalb ist dann Frankfurt virtuelles Ausland.
Aha. Menschen, wenn sie Funktionsträger sind. Funktion. Genau, also der Günther Öttinger zum Beispiel. Der war ja.
Der war ein beliebtes Beispiel. Ich glaube, das war auch vor allem wegen der wegen des amusement-Faktors, aber auf jeden Fall musste Günther Oettinger viel herhalten und dann wurde dann auch gefragt, ne, so aber wenn jetzt der Günther Oettinger,
über seine EU-Adresse mit seiner geliebten schreibt, ist er dann immer noch ein Funktionsträger und dann wurde es, ich weiß nicht, ob's eine definitive Antwort darauf gab, aber auf jeden Fall haben sich alle
amüsiert. Ich meine, manchmal kann man halt auch irgendwie, nachdem einem so neun Stunden das Gehirn gekocht wird, irgendwie fällt es auch schwer, ernst zu bleiben.
Man kann sich jetzt darüber beömmeln, aber Fakt ist, dass diese Art äh tatsächlich rechtliche Theorien waren
die im BND vertreten wurden. Man kann sich heute so ein bisschen darüber eher
Man kann darüber lachen, aber tatsächlich war es a unbekannt, dass sie diese Weltraumtheorie gab oder diese und ich habe wieder auch vorgetragen, so als sei,
Ähm der BND rechtssetzend, also wie die Regeln sind
Die Idee für Demo-T-Shirts. Ich bin ein Funktionsträger. Ich weiß gar nicht, vielleicht gab's da mal solche nee, ne? Gab's Funktionsträger wir haben auf jeden Fall Weltraum-Theorie-Aufkleber gemacht. Das haben wir schon gemacht, aber nee, Funktionsträger,
wusste ich nicht. Also
Ich glaube, wenn man jetzt auf die Geschichte, die Untersuchungsausschüsse blickt jetzt mal jemand große Picture macht, dann war natürlich dieser spezielle NSA BND Untersuchungsausschuss
anders. A
Weil Anna und Andre mitprotokolliert haben, ich denke, das war eine neue Art und der Bundestag musste damit umgehen. Hans-Christian Ströbeler etwa hat sich dafür explizit bedankt
als Arbeitshilfe, weil er nämlich auch beklagt hat, dass die offiziellen Protokolle so spät kommen, dass die keinen Sinn ergeben für ihn, aber es hat natürlich auch zum Teil Öffentlichkeit hergestellt, die erlarmt
Wenn der Untersuchungsausschuss einfach sehr lange tagt
Und ähnlich haben wir das jetzt so in Europa auch erlebt mit dem könnte man auch für andere sagen, ne? Aber es gab ja nicht nur uns tatsächlich, also es gab ja auch mehr quasi.
Leute, die da irgendwie viel Lebenszeit reingesteckt haben. Also wenn man jetzt überlegt, der Ausschuss war ja quasi.
Multimedial begleitet. Also wir haben,
Wir haben den Kram quasi mitgetippt und dann gab's ja auch noch irgendwie so eine so eine feste Crew aus Leuten, die dazu einen Podcast gemacht haben nach jeder Sitzung und wir saßen da ja irgendwie teilweise noch bis irgendwie nachts um eins, wenn der Kram dann vorbei war und haben direkt einen Podcast aufgenommen zu jedem
einzelnen Dingen daran noch mitgewirkt haben danach noch Statements gegeben. Technische Aufklärung heißt der. Ja genau und Stella hat das ja auch alles,
gezeichnet. Also so Stella war ja ganz
absucht als irgendwie, dass jemand dahin geht und sich jedes Mal hinsetzt und die Zeugen zeichnet und am Ende hat sie die sogar geknetet. Also nachdem du's mit dem Zeichnen so ein bisschen durch war, irgendwie hat sie angefangen Knetfiguren zu den Zeugen zu machen und ich meine, ich
Das ist äh war einfach glaube ich eine sehr ungewöhnliche Begleitung, die dann auch so ein bisschen im Gesamtpaket dafür gesorgt hat, dass das nicht einfach versickert
Aber es hat eben auch, glaube ich, bei den Abgeordneten mehr Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt. Also die haben schon,
eine Mehrzahl finde ich waren sehr aktiv und haben auch wirklich versucht diesen diesen
aufklärerischen da entgegenzuarbeiten. Die haben wirklich versucht rauszukriegen. Wir wissen natürlich nicht, was in den geheimen Sitzungen tatsächlich passiert ist, ja. Da ist eben immer noch ein Teil Opak. Da kann man nicht reingucken
Ja, ja. Aber jetzt mal vielleicht so, jetzt sind wir da jetzt mal so durchgegangen, aber auch was das vielleicht auch so an Community mit mitgetragen wurde.
Und äh wir haben ja schon gesagt, ne, es hat irgendwie viel Aufmerksamkeit auf diese Themen gebracht. Das ist dann vielleicht auch irgendwann so ein bisschen versickert, weil das halt ja wirklich über drei Jahre durchgezogen wurde, aber,
Was ist denn so für euch so der Impact oder auch irgendwie der Outcom gewesen und was für einen Einfluss hat's dann, was hat dieser Untersuchungsausschuss auch vielleicht verändert,
In der Gesamtwahrnehmung, also unabhängig, also dieses Thema NSA, BND, BND als Täter ist definitiv ein Teil davon, aber hat es noch mehr verändert.
Na, wenn man, ja, das ist ein bisschen, ich finde das so ein bisschen zweischneidig, ne. Auf der einen Seite, ich meine, es gab ja dann eine BND-Gesetzesreform, die einfach eine
absolute Enttäuschung war. So, das heißt, da hat sich was verändert, aber jetzt nicht zum Guten,
Weil es war ja von Anfang an klar, wahrscheinlich muss man am Ende nur das Gesetz reformieren, um,
Bessere einzuhegen, was dann passiert ist, dass eben ganz viel von dem, was festgestellt wurde, was der BND so tut, einfach legalisiert wurde.
Hat gesagt so ne,
Das wird mit einer fragwürdigen rechtlichen Theorie gestützt. Na, da machen wir jetzt mal ein richtiges Gesetz zu und das war so das Ergebnis. Also das harte Ergebnis war nicht so cool. Aber ich glaube, das,
weichere Ergebnis ist einfach, dass ich eine Menge Leute mit diesem Thema beschäftigen und auch irgendwie eine Menge an
so zivilgesellschaftlichem Engagement darum entstanden ist, sicherlich durch die Snowden Enthüllung sowieso schon
so an sich, aber auch eben durch diesen Ausschuss in Deutschland und dass wir jetzt wenigstens in einer Situation sind,
dass wenn wieder so ein komisches Gesetz kommt und das ist jetzt nicht das erste oder das letzte BND Gesetzreformchen irgendwie gewesen, dass es gab, dass dann zum Beispiel die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte hingeht und sagt, hier
Verfassungsbeschwerde und das hat ja irgendwie,
Schon mal geklappt und vielleicht klappt's dann eben auch wieder. Ja, ich glaube, ich würde das so ähnlich sehen. Also klar, im Ergebnis.
Hat man erstmal einen Bericht, da stehen ein paar Fakten drin, auf die sich alleinigern konnten, also die jetzt nicht in dem Sondervotum stehen, sondern wo man sagt, okay, das ist das Ergebnis berichtet, ist jetzt auch ein bisschen unabstreit
Ähm da waren sehr viele Quellen zusammengezogen
war ja ein langer Bericht und letztlich halt auch ein bisschen Hosen runter, fand ich in der Plenardebatte danach, weil sich ja dann äh die Regierungsparteien und die Oppositionsparteien auch sehr klar
gestellt haben und die haben sozusagen ihre politische Meinung dazu gesagt im Guten wie im im Schlechten sozusagen, ob sie den
Das für eine Massenüberwachung halten oder nicht, ja und ansonsten würde ich sagen, man hatte interessante Einblicke,
Ähm wie absurd das Theater da wird mit den Geheimdiensten. Na, ich finde, man hatte auch super interessante Einblicke, wie die denken,
Also das fand ich auch tatsächlich so ein so eine Metainformation was haben die für einen,
Bild von dem, was sie tun und was haben die so für ein Weltbild, wie verhalten die sich dazu.
Wie ist so dieses Verhältnis zu den USA, ne? Da hat man auch schon irgendwie dolle gemerkt, ne?
Auf keinen Fall, oh, wir wollen denen nicht auf die Füße treten und wenn wir jetzt hier irgendwas sagen, was denen nicht gefällt, ist alles ganz schlimm, weil wir können ja nix und wir sind ja so klein und irgendwie überhaupt. Wir sind der große Bruder, auf den sind wir angewiesen und so, also so diese ganze Metaebene von wegen wie laufen die Sachen da ab
Das fand ich auch ziemlich spannend,
Mhm, also ich würde denken, lernen kann man auf jeden Fall was und ich glaube, dass das auch für jeden Untersuchungsausschuss, egal welche Themen man jetzt nimmt, also
Habe jetzt zum Beispiel, weiß ich nicht, den Mautuntersuchungsausschuss nicht so direkt verfolgt oder Wirecard oder so, aber ich denke, das wird ähnlich. Also diese bestimmte Einblicke erlangt man da
Ähm trotzdem gibt's natürlich manchmal auch Parallelprozesse, also etwa bei den NSU-Untersuchungsausschüssen wurde gleich mehrere gehabt, weil nicht nur im Bundestag, sondern auch in den Landtagen, Untersuchungsausschüsse, wann hat man ja trotzdem noch parallel normales Gerichtsverfahren, wenn's um Straftaten geht.
Und ähm das ist eben eine andere Art von Einblick, würde ich sagen.
Ja, aber ich glaube, du brauchst auf jeden Fall auch jemanden, der es begleitet, weil das hast du ja also wie du sagst, ne, du weißt nicht so richtig, was das jetzt irgendwie bei Edathi so richtig passiert, daran erinnert man sich nicht mehr so richtig einmal sagen, was Edathi
Ach Gott ja. Für die Hörerinnen und ging ja um die sogenannte Operation Spate.
Da ging's um den Vorwurf ähm ob jemand kauft oder vielleicht auch
die liegen immer so, aber im im wesentlichen Kauf von Gewaltdarstellung und Missbrauchdarstellung von Kindern. Mhm. Und betroffen war eben auch ein Bundestagsabgeordneter mit dem Namen Eddadi, deswegen nannten die den Edati Untersuchungsausschuss und um die Frage, wer da was durchgestochen hatte,
Ähm ich denke, das war eins von einer von diesen Untersuchungsausschüssen, der
absolut politisch motiviert war. Da würde man gucken, ob man jemand so sagen soll, Behördenchefs oder Spitzenpolitiker beim Lügen erwischt. Würde sagen, das wird keine gesellschaftspolitische Relevanz hatte, wie wir das bei anderen Sachen gehört haben. Also wenn wir jetzt an den Cum-Ex,
Untersuchungsausschuss denken oder an den Wirecard. Das sind einfach Redenschaden zum und auch gesetzliche Missstände, die man da aufarbeitet und da kommen
so eine personalisierten wie der beim Edati oder so nicht rahmen. Würde ich sagen. Aber ja ein Instrument der Opposition und die kämpfen manchmal auch mit diesem Mittel
Aber nicht alle, würde ich sagen, ja, werden auch so eng begleitet. Nee, aber du hast ja zum Beispiel bei den NSU-Ausschüssen hattest du jetzt
NSU-Watch, die haben ja auch irgendwie eine krasse Arbeit gemacht und da gab's ja mehr als einen Untersuchungsausschuss zu und die haben, glaube ich, auch sehr geholfen, den ganzen Kram zu sortieren, weil das muss ja auch jemand machen. Ich habe mal im Zuge von dem,
NSA BND-Untersuchungsausschuss irgendwie mir die Sachen aus den alten Geheimdienst Untersuchungsausschüssen und den den ersten BND Untersuchungsausschuss irgendwie und.
Da sitzt du dann halt da und hast so ein paar alte Nachrichtenartikel und dann hast du irgendwie diesen Abschlussbericht und dann,
Weiß ich nicht, kannst du nicht viel mit anfangen, wenn da niemand ist, der das mal wirklich irgendwie versucht aufzubereiten und mal irgendwie darstellt, sodass es ein Mensch konsumieren kann. Da muss ich schon wieder in äh Hans-Christian Schröbele denken, den Eis,
Podcast mit dem auf äh nahm, da räumte er grad seinen Bundestagsbüro nach vielen Jahrzehnten und hatte ich weiß nicht, wie viele Meter ganz viele
also meterweise Akten und da hatte sich auch vorgenommen, diese Untersuchungsausschuss, also gerade im Bereich der Geheimdienste, mal aufzuarbeiten, weil das auch für notwendig hält, immer wieder gab's in den Untersuchungsausschüssen auch Verfassungsbeschwerden
ähm Fraktionen, die sich um ihre Rechte geprägt
gesehen haben, sich an den Verfassungsgericht gewandt haben immer wieder und teilweise auch Recht bekommen haben. Also die die Rechte, die die Parlamentarier oder jeweils die Fraktionen haben, sind auch manchmal umstritten. Wenn natürlich der auch mit harten Bandagen gekämpft wird, wenn's
wirklich ums Eingemachte geht und wenn ihr Geheimdienst ist, glaube ich
besonders hart, äh die sich dieses diese Selbstverständlichkeit rausnehmen, dass sie im Prinzip nicht berichten müssen oder nicht ordentlich kontrolliert gehören, weil sie sind ja Geheimdienste ja ist halt glaube ich da besonders verbreitet. Schnäuble konnte sich ja sehr empörend drüber.
Mit Recht. Also er hatte aber auch viel Erfahrung in dem Sinne, dass es auch teilweise.
Ähm also entnahm das auch mit einem gewissen Humor. Das war hast du wahrscheinlich beim Protokollieren auch mitbekommen oder? Ja, aber ich glaube, irgendwann haben das alle mit so einem gewissen Humor genommen, weil das hältst du ja auch anders nicht
aus. Also so du wirst ja auch also.
Das heißt, du wirst nur die Parlamentarier, die da unten sitzen, werden ja auch teilweise so richtig hart verarscht. Also so, wo du denkst
ne die waren auch teilweise wütend. Auch die Leute von der CDU, ne, wo du denkst, ne, die sind ja sehr geheimdienstfreundlich gewesen und so, aber wenn da jemand sitzt und irgendwie,
komplett Verweigerung hinlegt, wie der eine Typ, der dann der sollte irgendeinem CDU-Menschen,
erklären, wie das mit der Langwellenkommunikation funktioniert. So, also so eine Frage, ganz normale Frage, nix Geheimes. So, wie funktioniert das technisch? Und dann meint er so,
Ja also,
Ich bin hier nicht geladen, um Ihnen die Wikipedia vorzulesen. Das mache ich nicht. So und dann denkst du so, dann wirst du irgendwann einfach, also nächster, willst du ihm irgendwie an den Hals springen? Also da musst du ja irgend so eine einen Copingmechanismus,
Und das ist halt eben spannend so, dass so Beamten so was dann,
Abliefern teilweise, wo jeder normale Sachverständige dann wahrscheinlich gesagt hatte, ja klar erkläre ich dir das kurz
Bin ja hier, weil ich dir was erklären soll, ähm dass das halt schon so ein so eine also so eine feindeshaltung gar keinen Bock kein
Bock auf gar nix. Das hat er auch richtig hart raushängen lassen. Kommt noch ein Aspekt dazu, den du schon paar Mal erwähnt hast, nämlich das sind immer oder sehr oft sehr, sehr lange ging und dann einfach auch eine gewisse persönliche Erschöpfung dazukam auf beiden Seiten,
Ja. Also auf drei Seiten bei euch oben auf der also ihr sagt ja immer also ihr habt oben drauf ist das auch oder?
Ja, wobei die oft erst nachher kamen. Also einmal hatte ich die Erschöpfung auch während der Sitzung, weil da war ich nämlich irgendwie in der Mittagspause in der Bundestagskantine und habe Maultaschenauflauf
und das war furchtbar. Es war so eine riesige Portion und es war sehr lecker und es war sehr viel Käse drüber und dann war diese
blöde Mittagspause vorbei und ich bin in diesem Sitzungssaal und ich hatte Sekundenschlaf am Rechner, während ich getippt
Habe, weil ich irgendwie dieses Fett sich in meinem Magen irgendwie alles Blut war irgendwie dann in meinem Verdauungstrakt und es war vorbei. So, aber ansonsten tatsächlich regulärerweise kam die Müdigkeit erst danach,
Also die Essensversorgung im Bundestag wäre eigentlich auch meine eigene Folge dicke Bretterwerte Currywurst im Casino.
Vielleicht also das können wir dann ja vielleicht auch noch mal als Prozess mit aufnehmen, äh wie die äh die die Nahrungsmittelversorgung im Bundestag zu bestimmten Phänomenen.
Ähm,
Also vielleicht äh wollen wir wir haben ja jetzt über den NSU-Besuchungsuntersuchungsausschuss auch gesprochen und auch dadrüber gesprochen, dass es da auch parallel mehrere Untersuchungsausschüsse gibt. Es ist nämlich auch so, dass es nicht nur,
Im Bundestag Untersuchungsausschuss gibt da natürlich auch in den einzelnen Landtagen können Untersuchungsausschüsse entstehen und da ist natürlich dann auch wieder die Frage läuft es dann genauso ab?
Rechtlich, wie die zusammengesetzt werden, haben die genauso viele Rechte wie so ein Untersuchungsausschuss im Bundestag oder ist das dann auf das Land begrenzt?
Das ist ja dann auch noch mal eine Frage und warum macht man das überhaupt noch so zusätzlich? Also ich habe mir in eiligen Bundesländern mal so angesehen über die Geschichte der Bundesrepublik, wie das so.
Also erstmal zahlenmäßig verteilt ist und dabei habe ich bemerkt, dass die meisten Bundesländer die Untersuchungsausschüsse haben, eher eine zunehmende Tendenz haben
Also schon durchaus vier oder fünfäh pro Legislaturperiode, während
zum Beispiel in den sechziger Jahren oder so mal einer war und manchmal auch gar keiner in der Legislaturperiode. Also es ist offenbar ein Mittel der Opposition geworden, ist das auch in Landtagen, was häufiger genutzt wird.
Aber man sieht, wenn man sich die Themen durchsieht, dass es wenige Untersuchungsausschüsse sind, die wirklich jetzt eine,
äh bundespolitische Relevanz haben, die bleiben dann oft eben klar auf landespolitischer Ebene. Es gibt Ausnahmen. Ich denke, das zählt für alle NSU-Untersuchungsausschüsse oder solche, zum Beispiel in Nordrhein-Westfalen gab's den Anis Amri Untersuchungsausschuss. Also wir
Genau und sonst ist es sehr wahrscheinlich eher so im Kleineren irgendwie als das Landesnetz NRW ausgefallen ist. Da gab's auch einen Untersuchungsausschuss. Da waren die jetzt im Bundesland besonders betroffen. Äh interessiert jetzt die Bundesebene nicht nicht so wirklich, wobei
Die Verwaltungsdigitalisierung kann davon mit Sicherheit lernen, aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Also man sieht, nimmt etwas zu, aber also aus meiner Sicht ist das nicht extensiv benutzt, ähm sondern hält sich immer noch so im Rahmen drei bis fünf ähm sind schon viel in der Legislaturperiode. Geht auch für den Bundestag. Ähm,
Weißt du, wann's die meisten gab im Bundestag? Nee, sag mal, tatsächlich in der ersten Wahlperiode ab neunundvierzig. Da gab's neun.
Okay, das ist wirklich das Feld aus der Reihe so viel habe ich jetzt in den letzten ja vier Jahrzehnten sonst nicht gesehen. Nee.
Da ging's nicht nur quasi um irgendwie Ex-Nazis, die dann noch in Wundungsbehörden sitzen, sondern gibt's eine ganz absurde Sachen, irgendwie eine.
Katastrophe wurde untersucht im Bundestag, wo ich auch noch nicht so genau weiß, warum eigentlich also ich glaube, da gab's aber sehr, sie sind eine große Grubenunglücke da gab's so ein riesiges Unglück, ne? Und dann gab's irgendwie man hat den,
Kraftstoffvertrieb hat man auch untersucht. Ist auf jeden Fall,
Donnerstag auch zum Abgasskandal gab's also das heute auch so. Ich würde gerne mal Mäuschen spielen und irgendwie in
Anfang der Sechziger oder so
da mal sitzen und mir mal anhören, wie damals zu sagen der Usus war, wie die sich unterhalten haben. Ich würde's gerne mal machen. Ich find's superschade, dass es nicht aufgezeichnet weil ich denke, die politische Kultur wird sich enorm gewandelt das vielleicht noch mal da ganz zum Schluss, ne? Wir haben jetzt gesagt, das
Es gab Protokolle, es gibt öffentliche Sitzungen, es gibt geheime Sitzungen. Woran liegt das denn? Das haben wir, glaube ich, jetzt noch nicht so richtig gesagt, dass solche Sachen nicht aufgezeichnet werden.
Na ja einmal im Gesetz selbst. Der ist sozusagen nicht vorgesehen, dass das Bild und Tonaufnahmen gibt, aber der Ausschuss selber kann sich entscheiden dazu
Also das ist sozusagen die Ford
nicht mit Ton und Film, aber es ist grundsätzlich erst mal öffentlich. Daran würde ich sagen, liegt das unter den Landtagen ist es ja immer so ähnlich wie im Bundestag. Okay. Aber wir könnten mal im Vergleich die EU nehmen da?
Gab's ähm in dem Untersuchungsausschuss jetzt der gerade beendet wurde zum
Pegasus-Skandal, also Staatsregierung und ähnliche Späßsoftware, keine Form von Geheimhaltung. Fand ich ganz interessant. Da wurde ja auch in hohem Maße Geheimdienste betrifft, wusste ich nicht,
Ähm da gab's
immer nur öffentliche Sitzungen. Die waren zwar teilweise schwer nachzuvollziehen, weil der Untersuchungsausschuss sich auf die Reise gemacht hat. Die haben also Länder in Europa besucht,
Weil's nicht immer so, dass man den Stream gucken konnte, aber grundsätzlich gab's da keine Geheimhaltung, mit fand ich einen interessanten Unterschied
Na ja, über die Leute, die irgendwie was Geheimnis hätten, sagen können, sind ja auch einfach nicht gekommen. Ja. Genau. Das ist nämlich der zweite Unterschied. Also vielleicht machen wir noch mal einen Schritt zurück, sondern wir reden über den.
Im EU-Sprecher ist ja der Pega-Ausschuss, der beschäftigt sich mit dem gesamten Pegasus-Skandal und versucht es sozusagen zu untersuchen und aufzuklären, vielleicht auch ein Stück weit und der ist jetzt, der der wurde immer wieder mal verlängert. Ich weiß nicht, wann sie angefangen haben
Äh vor einem Jahr ziemlich genau. Vor einem mehr als ein Jahr. Ja genau. Sie haben ihn aber verlängert, glaube ich zwischendurch. Wir haben ihn verlängert. Ich glaube, um irgendwie drei Monate oder so. Ja. Oder sechs. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ähm,
Und ich glaube, du warst da auch als Expertin geladen. Linus war auch da. Ich ich Andre war da. Ja. Ja, Andre war der einzige, der dann da war ähm.
Also der einzige zu zu Deutschland, nicht aus Deutschland. Cons war ja auch da, aber zu einem anderen Zeitpunkt zu einem wesentlich früheren Zeitpunkt als Andre da bei Andre ist das ja erst ein paar Monate her. Du warst
Ich weiß nicht, wann was die zweite Sitzung, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, also ganz am Anfang der Prozedere ist einfach weniger formalisiert,
Auch relativ kurzfristig, also meine eigene Einladung war da, glaube ich, weiß ich nicht, zwei Wochen vorher. Also mit wenig vorher Lauf
auch freier in diesen Gesprächen, ja. Die haben wirklich äh da gibt's eine dialogische Komponente, ist eher locker, moderiert und ähm die ziehen auch nicht so viel Akten bei, sondern die haben eben eher Leute befragt
Und Sie haben das Recht, Studienauftrag zu geben und haben Sie auch getan, die haben drei größere Studien in Auftrag gegeben, wo Sie vor allen Dingen die Rechtslage beleuchten. Ähm,
setzt es mir aus dem deutschen Untersuchungsausschuss so nicht bekannt. Also jedenfalls im NSA BND-Untersuchungsausschuss gab's da auch eine Studie, außer die vom Sonderermittler gab's da eigentlich nix oder?
Also wenn mir keiner aber kann,
Nee, ich glaube, drumrum gab's bestimmt so ne die Parlamentarier können ja so den wissenschaftlichen Dienst oder die wissenschaftlichen Dienste des Bundestags beauftragen. Ich glaube, da gab's bestimmt Sachen, aber jetzt vom Ausschuss selber,
Wüsste ich nicht,
über dick wahrscheinlich auch an der Struktur der EU, also sehr viele Rechtsräume. Jeder EU-Stadt hat ein eigenes. Ähm glaube auch ein schwieriger zu beackerndes Feld
denn viele dieser Fragen im Zusammenhang mit dem Staatstrojaner Skandal um Pegasus ist Nationalrecht eigentlich mit der EU nichts zu tun,
Subsudiaritätsprinzip ist dann halt äh funkt dann da halt extrem mit rein ähm und also ich glaube es ist auch einfacher, da dürfen die Abgeordneten ja teilweise auch selber die Fraktion,
Das war ja alles relativ lose mit den Einladungen, sage ich mal so. Ähm genau, der Pilgerausschuss wurde verlängert.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was die Begründung war, warum sie den verlängert haben, weil sie noch nicht fertig waren mit Untersuchung, glaube ich.
Wahrscheinlich. Die sind auch gefühlt noch nicht fertig, ist jetzt eigentlich abgeschlossen dieser Ausschuss und der hat auch nicht so. Also ich habe das Gefühl, der hat nicht so viel, also dieser Pegasus war natürlich irgendwie
riesig und der hat extrem viel mediale Aufmerksamkeit bekommen. Der Untersuchungsausschuss jetzt letztendlich gefühlt aber gar nicht so. Also,
es liegt auch daran, dass im letzten Jahr in der EU und ne und ganz viele Dinge kreuz und quer und so und dann gab's
noch den den Skandal und hier Skandal, aber am Ende des Tages muss ich sagen, fand ich's extrem.
Ja, fast besorgniserregend, wie wenig dieser Pilgerausschuss in der Öffentlichkeit stattgefunden hat und wie wenig der auch irgendwie.
Durchgeschlagen hat. Also so richtig was davon gehört, hat man ja dann,
mich. Nee, aber der produziert hier auch keine Skandale, ne? Also ich meine, all die Leute, die da was sagen könnten, was irgendwie dazu führen könnte, dass ein Skandal entsteht, die müssen da ja nicht hinkommen, weil die können ja nicht sagen, hier,
Weiß ich nicht, wer benutzt Pegasus in Deutschland, der BND,
BKA genau hier, ihr müsst jetzt hierherkommen und uns quasi sagen, was ihr damit macht. Die müssen da nicht hingehen. So und dann kommt halt und die müssen denen nix sagen und wenn du halt irgendwie die entsprechenden Leute nicht hast, sondern,
Vor allem Sachverständige hatten Sie ja da und Betroffene von Pegasus hatten Sie da und tatsächlich auch die Leute von.
Schon ein bisschen Skandal drin. Genau, aber das war auch glaube ich so das Einzige, wo so ein bisschen Potential drinne war, oder? Na ja, sie hätten sich, glaube ich, etwas mehr versprochen von ihren Reisen
stark betroffenen Staaten wie etwa Spanien, Polen oder Griechenland, die ja so ziemlich große staatstreue Skandale auch mit Rücktritten
Da hatten Sie sich, glaube ich, mir versprochen, sind da aber auch teilweise aufgelaufen, weil einfach die Verantwortlichen überhaupt nicht mit den Ausschussmitgliedern gesprochen haben. Sie wird zwar eingereist, aber guten Tag kam halt keiner
und auch in Deutschland also BKA ist nicht erschienen und auch kein Regierungsvertreter. Ähm dennoch glaube ich, dass das auch hier so ist wie beim NSA, BND Untersuchungsausschuss. Ich würde schon sagen, Erkenntnis,
Potential ist groß und auch hier gab's einen Abschlussbericht und eine Plenardebatte, die auch recht also klar die die einfach dazugehört,
Aber vieles von zumindest den technischen und rechtlichen Erkenntnissen war jetzt nicht wirklich neu, sondern schon zuvor publiziert.
Also insofern ja, es gibt da noch einen Unterschied,
an dem man vielleicht äh zum Bundestag machen kann, nämlich die Empfehlungen, die haben so eine Art ja, lange Liste, ein ein Recordations, also Empfehlungen rausgegeben
Die die hat auch ähm angenommen wurden. Die richten sich aber dann eher an die einzelnen EU-Staaten, insbesondere die, die
Na und an die Kommission. Die Kommission muss ja nix damit machen. Es sind ja Empfehlungen. Genau. Na ja schon. Sie haben eine Frist bis November,
und jetzt muss die EU-Kommission mal irgendwie handeln, aber jetzt nicht handeln. Also,
Das ist halt wahrscheinlich so, ne? Wir haben Gesetze, wir haben Richtlinien und wir haben Empfehlungen von Untersuchungsausschüssen. Da wissen wir halt auch genau,
Wie das läuft und äh ich sage mal, bei der aktuellen Tendenz der Kommission ist da, glaube ich, nicht so viel zu erwarten und ausm Rat, ich weiß nicht, den Rat betrifft es halt nicht, aber.
Weiß ich nicht, die können das wahrscheinlich relativ gut skippen, sage ich mal so, also die allgemeine Erklärung der Menschenrechte,
und du die UN-Mitglieder skippen sie sich ja auch im Zweifelsfall so durch. Meine Hoffnungen sind natürlich auch gering, aber wichtig schränkt mir hier generell die Rolle der Presse.
Auch wenn der Ausschuss an sich auch in den einzelnen Ländern wenig begleitet wurde, ist natürlich die ganze Rolle der Presse hier enorm wichtig. Die hatte Pegasus Projekt überhaupt erst ins Leben gerufen. Das ist ja ein internationales Konsortium ähm von
Medienhäusern. Ich glaube, es hätte sonst gar nicht diesen Untersuchungsausschuss gegeben. Die haben ja erst aufgedeckt, wer so betroffen wurde.
Nee und auch im Laufe des Ausschusses. Ich meine diese ganze Griechenlandnummer kam ja auch erst als der Ausschuss lief so die Spaniennummer ja oder? Also da war's ja auch so. Der der Untersuchungsgegenstand,
während der Untersuchung. Wobei man jetzt natürlich sagen muss, ne, wenn's jetzt um den Schutz von Journalistinnen vor Spywe-Geschichten geht, hat
scheint die EU ja nicht wirklich was daraus gelernt zu haben, wenn man sich jetzt die aktuelle Gesetzgebungslage da anschaut, ne? Sie sind auch oft gar nicht zuständig, denn Nationalstaaten die einzelnen Gesetzgeber zuständig. Trotzdem findet
die Ermahnungen, die Sie jetzt da reingeschrieben haben, schon relativ deutlich sind die rechtswidrigkeiten, die Sie festgestellt haben in den Mitgliedsländern
Sind nun mal erstmal dokumentiert. Nicht so interessieren, aber okay. Ich meine und du läufst immer gegen die Wand, wenn jemand sagt, nationale Sicherheit,
dann hast du halt verloren als EU machen was du willst.
Na ja, also Untersuchungsausschüsse ein äh sehr aufschlussreiches, aber auch sehr frustrierendes Thema. Ähm.
Mal sehen, wie's weitergeht, wann wir den nächsten Untersuchungsausschuss haben,
Ich weiß es nicht. Vielleicht bekommen wir ja mal irgendeinen zur Chatkontrolle, weil ähm wie ist das denn mit dem virtuellen Ausland und der Chatkontrolle,
die mir so direkt in den Kopf kam, ähm weil's ja EU-Ausland ist und es ist ja eigentlich nicht betroffen.
Genau ähm ja vielen Dank, dass du da warst Anna. Ja danke für die Einladung. Ähm das nächste Mal,
Machen wir mal was, was gar nicht so direkt was mit Politik schon sagen? Spoilern? Also genau äh nächstes Mal ist dann auch Elisa hoffentlich wieder da, weil die auch wirklich sehr viel Expertise in diesem Bereich hat und da soll's jetzt mal endlich um das Thema Standardisierung,
gehen und ähm insbesondere um,
Ja, ich würde sagen, Verschlüsselung und Interoperabilität. Ähm und zwar nicht aus der Perspektive,
Digital Markets Act, sondern aus der Perspektive, wie kommen denn eigentlich solche Standards zu
Zustande. Wie ist das eigentlich so ein Standard zu schreiben und ähm wie bringt man den eigentlich dann durch und ein?
Nee. Denn wir hatten uns ja für dicke Bretter vorgenommen, so ein bisschen auf Regulierung zu gucken und irgendwie sind äh Stadisierungen von Protokollen, also von technischen Protokollen, ne, die Teil davon fanden wir und deswegen haben wir uns auch zwei Leute, glaube ich, eingeladen, die uns
Nach hoffentlich guter Auskunft geben können an diesem speziellen Beispiel. Ja, damit würde ich sagen,
Wir können die dicken Bretter, die wir heute gebohrt haben, jetzt mal beenden und wollen uns bedanken für die Aufmerksamkeit und nehmen eure Kommentare gerne entgegen bei Kaufradio DE,
Nicht wahr? Also wenn ihr noch was schreiben wollt, dann gerne dazu. Wir nehmen auch noch Vorschläge für andere Themen, die wir mal durchbohren sollten.
Genau und ansonsten hören wir uns.
Oktober? Richtig? Richtig und dazwischen gibt es natürlich auch noch ein reguläres Chaosradio. Ähm,
Das spoilern wir jetzt aber nicht. Nee, sind wir da gar nicht sicher. Genau. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Music.